[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
episode of our weekly anime newscast the
links are in the description
recommendations go in the comment just
last week we launched our anime uproar
patreon and we already have our first
patron so huge thank you to sha tous a
lovely tsundere and Gilgamesh your
support means a lot to us with the whole
YouTube ad boycott mess we're probably
earning like a tenth of what we would
have been earning before the boycott and
we were not earning much to begin with
so basically what we get on patreon is
what we're earning period so again
thanks guys for your support it means a
lot to us and if you want to check out
our patreon I will put the link in the
description but enough about YouTube
stuff did you know that there is
apparently a sequel in production for
the classic Ghibli film My Neighbor
Totoro yeah apparently there is a My
Neighbor Totoro - in production right
now called Totoro returns at least
according to the Studio Ghibli wiki my
thanks to store Lee from the discord
server for sending me a link to the
Studio Ghibli wiki entry on my neighbor
totoro - which is supposed to be coming
out in May of 2018 let's see what the
wiki says My Neighbor Totoro - Totoro
Returns is the upcoming second main
sequel film of My Neighbor Totoro this
film is to be directed by Goro Miyazaki
of Studio Ghibli and is scheduled for a
during May 2018 released by Toho this
film is in celebration of the My
Neighbor Totoro 30th anniversary and
will be distribution by G kids now aside
from the terrible grammar there is no
evidence whatsoever that this movie is
in production there is no IMDB entry for
this film even though the wiki says that
there is an IMDB entry there is no
official Wikipedia entry on the film or
any information whatsoever that this
movie is being made
the only My Neighbor Totoro sequel that
we know of is a 13 minute short film
called May and the kitten bus which was
released in 2002 and which is sometimes
displayed at the Studio Ghibli Museum
but it was never released outside of the
museum
a-and the kitten buzz tells a story of
may's friendship with the child over the
original cat bus from the film and again
like I said there is no evidence of any
additional sequels in production even
though the Studio Ghibli wiki entry that
I'm talking about specifically says that
this new movie my neighbor told her to
should not be confused with Mae and the
kitten bus frankly there has been a
whole lot of fake news in the anime
community lately from a supposed
confirmation of a yuria night season -
in October - the confirmation of the
seven deadly sins season two then a
seven deadly sin season three and all
this kind of stuff and this again looks
to me like another fake story just
another sort of clickbait fake story as
like huge fan of Studio Ghibli I will of
course keep my eye out for any news
about upcoming films or sequels however
for now I have to say that this story
looks like just a troll to me in Code
Geass news a major Japanese TV station
called Sun TV just announced that they
will be airing reruns of the original
Code Geass series every Thursday and
while as fans of Code Geass what we
really want is news about the sequel
this again gives us a good idea about
the height for Code Geass in Japan the
fact that a major Japanese TV station is
airing reruns of this show that finished
airing in 2008 is a good sign about the
huge amount of interest for Code Geass
in the future
my thanks to curry Gohan from the server
for giving me a heads up about this news
and another Code Geass news you might
remember that about two weeks ago we
made a video about the new Code Geass PV
that was shown at anime Japan 2017 this
PV was part of the Bondi visual booth at
the event and now Bondi visual has
uploaded a high-definition version of
the video onto YouTube this video
includes clips of a bunch of Bondi anime
but the Code Geass PV starts at 11
minutes and 47 seconds
thanks to anime world and soul maka from
the discord for informing me about this
and as you can see there is a ton of
activity going on on our discord servers
so if you want to join us the link is in
the description back on Saturday our boy
and rant cafe regular makkal not
uploaded a new video
this channel and this one was all about
anime clickbait along with mac himself
this video features special guest
appearances from yours truly
along with tony the black Critic guy
Briggs from all-day anime cyanide
blizzard bred from brands fandoms and
proving that she is indeed still alive
we have simply rose from Korea this was
a great video it was a pleasure seeing
rose again after a while and Tony the
black Critic I said that I deserve an
Oscar for best supporting role in this
video which means a lot because we all
know that Tony is an expert film critic
so yes thanks Tony and great job Mac be
sure to check out this video this week
we also had Noble aka lost paws upload a
special video where he thanked his fans
for reaching over 1 million subscribers
noble was really emotional in this video
it was pretty heartwarming to see and
this is also big news for the anime
community because now after mystique
renege SIA and the anime man Noble is
another anime youtuber who reached over
1 million subscribers and I know that
Aki Dearest is going to reach this
milestone very very soon as well which
again speaks to the fact that the anime
community on YouTube is growing the
anime fan base in general is growing and
this bodes well for all anime fans and
anime youtubers one of my absolutely
favorite artists on YouTube pehle k
recently uploaded his cover of the new
attack on titan season 2 opening i know
that some people were complaining about
the season 2 opening but I'm liking it
it's starting to grow on me
and as always fellow K did a great job
with this cover it is epic so you have
to check it out and speaking of attack
on Titan season 2 my favorite a MV for
this week was an attack on Titan season
2 a MV by warlocks AMD's I featured
warlocks and V's in these weekly videos
multiple times because I think he is an
excellent MV creator he works hard makes
a ton of a MVS and he always does such a
great job with him so you have to check
out this guy's channel if you're an avid
fan and that is it for this week guys if
you enjoyed these videos be sure to LIKE
and subscribe and until next time see ya
space cowboy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]